[Musique]
oui bien menée par l'hadopi c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine je
vous parlais d'une série de vidéos sont
sortis sur les médias sociaux et
maintenant on voit aussi dans les grands
médias puisqu'il passe au téléjournal
par exemple je parle de deux camps fin
quand même assez différentes de vidéos
une est une satire etc j'ai un ami blanc
et ses vidéos la satire il vraiment
certaines des interactions réel son
véhicule quotidiennement par les
légendes et communauté autochtone
lorsqu'ils rencontrent des personnes qui
n'ont pas souvent en interaction avec
des membres des communautés autochtones
ça fait des commentaires sur comment on
s'exprime notre langue notre culture
notre nourriture qui différence à 110
heures chez nous mais il ya un dégré ou
est ce que c'est le miroir et tourner
vers la communauté qui elle ne reçoit
pas souvent ce genre de distinction et
ce qui est fait c'est pas juste point de
vue autochtone mais aussi le point de
vue des personnes qui sont racisées et
il y en a beaucoup au québec qui
malheureusement vu ce genre même genre
de discours nommé avec des termes et des
thèmes très différents
et là ça me permet de parler de l'autre
vidéo aussi qui va parler de ces deux
réalités là etc les vidéos de rap qui
est sorti sur le racisme systémique un
excellent vidéo qui parle des
témoignages qui multiplie témoignages
d'enfants de 5 à des personnes de 75 ans
sur qu'est ce qu'il vit comme racisme et
comme racisme systémique bien sûr les
gens disent arrêter d'en parler vous
allez tellement vous allez saturer les
gens sur leur racisme seek amy et moi je
pense que c'est ce qui a fait que j'ai
très contente de voir ses vidéos là à
paraître c'est qu'il faut une multitude
de voix il faut des témoignages il faut
des visions pour les émotions et le vécu
des gens et c'est pour ça que les vidéos
sont si importants par rapport à la
réconciliation entre les citoyens
c'est certain que quand on entend parler
d'une chose la première fois qu'en plus
ça implique une émotion qui peut mettre
en cause son identité propre
son histoire sa réalité c'est très
difficile de vouloir en entend tous les
jours parce qu'il faut déjà en plus
digérer toute cette information mais
avoir plus en plus d'informations vous
permettre de distinguer justement les
différents témoignages stang et ckoi du
racisme ordinaire et du racisme
systémique parce qu'on manque de
témoignages
on manque d'exemple claire distinction
c'est pendant le discours courant mais
il faut marteler ces mots là puisque ce
sont des réalités qui existent et qui
sont vraies cependant on voit
présentement dans le discours du
gouvernement
le discours de certains chroniqueurs qui
viennent dans les grands médias disent
nous on reconnaît pas le racisme
systémique
c'était cd terme fourre tout et c'est
certain que c'est des termes faut aussi
en décidant de ne pas vouloir le
reconnaître on ne veut pas 76 en
apprendre plus sur la terminologie sur
les distinctions sauf qu est ce qui fait
qu'il ya un racisme qui d'ordinaire est
un racisme etc liés dans le système
alors en temps je ne le reconnais pas on
utilise un privilège de décider
qu'est ce qui grouille dans les médias
qu'est-ce qui est un sujet qu'on peut
parler
et qu'est ce qui justement ne nous
intéresse pas et souvent mais c'est la
réalité
les témoignages des gens qui sont ils
font partie des sociétés en marge de la
société plus grande et je vais vous dire
un exemple pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
des vox pop pour savoir qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous de nouvelles saveurs de
chip est ce que vous aimez la dernière
série qui est sorti on va demander des
témoignages à des gens dans la vue sur
tous ces sujets là eh oui là il ya de la
place dans les médias pour ça mais quand
et des enjeux qui sont difficiles qui
doivent être décortiquées doivent être
développées et bien des fois où on voit
pas vraiment vox pop là-dessus on va pas
demander à des communautés de parler de
leur propre réalité va vouloir entendre
plus parler de soi même d'une façon
positive et on va vouloir éviter
justement le discours qui nous remet en
question et qu'il nous demande de
travailler justement sur la relation du
quotidien hélas les vidéos comme moi
aussi j'ai un ami black faucon avec un
très grand dreux degré du mot
vidéo de rades comporte des témoignages
d'enfants de 5 ans à 75 ans de leur
réalité avec le racisme au quotidien
mais on regarde aussi vidéo qui existe
comme la wapikoni mobile depuis des
années en même des témoignages jamais la
réalité des communautés autochtones
ils font découvrir les pendants
justement culturel qui seraient touchés
par nation donc plus va y avoir des
vidéos plus il va y avoir des
témoignages visuels dans lequel les gens
vont pouvoir se plonger dans la réalité
et voir un humain témoigner de sa
réalité et mieux je pense que cette
réalité de réconciliation là va se
mettre en place et pas juste être un
concept qui flottent entre les
gouvernements donc j'espère que vous
allez visiter ces vidéos là vous allez
découvrir d'eau et j'espère que vous
avez continué à regarder vous aurez
ouvert pour entendre parler de ce sujet
parce qu'il est d'actualité il l'aide à
venir vous souhaite une belle semaine